I I just watched the the running man
this week
and at the beginning I did there is this
preamble where they talk about what
america is gonna be like in 2017
and it's about a militarized state and
an economic collapse and depleted
natural resources are not
I'm watching this they can they're just
three years off because it
it's basically happening now did you
realize that that movie
although we have we don't have reality
jail just yet but I think we probably
worry I dvd-a
do you realize that movie was gonna be
so ahead of its time no really I didn't
you know it was a fun movie to do with
richard Dawson an arnold in all the
happy hours
at the premise of the show he did you
know we're actually wrote the running
man are you aware that you know what I
did my research before I don't remember
I had tell me please
well here's it well here's to be all the
running man was a
are short story written in a book buyer
a writer named Richard Bachman
well that was a shoot member Stephen
King Stephen King wrote the running man
is that right I can't believe it you
know when I guess what I was doing
research before I watched it again the
other day
I would have sworn it was a Philip K
Dick because that was all his
his future and no yeah nope Stephen King
Stephen King wrote under the pseudonym
Richard Bachman he wrote the running man
and what it is with the game show or the
future well with reality TV like it is
today
and when you look at where we're at
right now in 2017
the running man might be real H three
years away
yeah it really between ratings and are
poor profit prisons which we already
have a definite possibility
so I gotta ask you when you did that
movie and you did predator both with
arnold schwarzenegger
did you guys ever do you have a
political talk to do everything a you
know what maybe
maybe we'll be governors one day where
you think not a bit
you know when we did predator in fact I
did predator in are all came up to me I
miss at mister just three
my next film the running man there's a
part you're perfect for I hope you will
do it
well it always get when you deal with
Hollywood
when the star of the film watch %um is
the OMA
it gives you great leverage on
negotiating the app
bet that mary had a little higher
learning to learn where
when the star want you in the film that
means you've got some leverage when it
comes time to negotiate then
believe me I exploited that leverage
well speaking up leverage did you get to
keep the gun
literally the coolest done probably in
the history of filmmaking did they let
you keep it
no not at all that's the helicopter may
be gone no I was the first person in
predator 2 should have held it shoots
shop
seven thousand rounds a minute I think
something like that
it's a it's a gavel in god knows what it
is rich I was shooting a full ammo load
didn't kick me out much just torque to
the left a little goes
the barrel swing counterclockwise but
the unique thing about the god music
electronically fire there's no trigger
they would run battery cables up my
pants legging out display should into
the weapon
and their I could be guy in the bushes I
was tied for me to shoot
he touched the two adds to the car
batteries I'd start firing wow that is
unbelievable what what was your classic
line there do you remember it
I ain't got time to bleed I